voilà alors suite à ce scandale et à
ceux qui l'avaient précédé la ligue des
droits de l'homme a décidé de réagir et
vous a demandé muriel et guy d'être ici
leurs outils médiatiques
j'en lis un texte dont nous sommes pas
les auteurs mais que nous pourrions
signer dès demain pour une autre
politique de l'immigration appel à
l'insurrection des consciences des
hommes des femmes des enfants sont
aujourd'hui pour chassé traqué empêcher
de vivre ce sens les sans papiers fuyant
misère et dictature souvent au péril de
leur vie
victimes de réseaux mafieux qui vivent
de la fermeture de nos frontières
leur seul tort est de vouloir vivre à
toute force et quand je fais un avenir
meilleur pour leurs enfants
le gouvernement les transforme
aujourd'hui en gibier et en boucs
émissaires des maux de la société
française à l'arbitraire de la loi
s'ajoute celui des pâtes pratiques
administratives sous la pression d'une
politique du chiffre
ignorant toute humanité les drames
deviennent quotidiens voir ses enfants
arrêtés en classe comme un pas en être
séparée arbitrairement le pouvoir se
soigner décemment se loger contre des
murs suintant la misère parfois y
laisser sa vie celle de ces gosses se
fait exploiter par des négriers sous
l'oeil complaisant des pouvoirs publics
avoir la peur au ventre à chaque
mouvement la rue devenant l'espace de
sécurité légale c'est la vie quotidienne
de dizaines de milliers de personnes
dans la france de 2005 toutes les
déclarations martiales
ils changeront en rien les étrangers en
situation régulière sont victimes même
ostracisme associés insidieusement au
terrorisme et à la délinquance
puis les français qu'ils leur
ressemblent subissent les mêmes avanies
les mêmes violences policières
enfin tous les habitants de francs sont
fichés
parce que simplement il accueille
parents ou amis cette politique porteuse
de désespoir de haine et de xénophobie
semble être tolérée même de ceux qui par
leur histoire leur principe
devraient y être les plus opposés elle
est indigne des principes qui fondent
une démocratie elle est le contraire de
la france que nous aimons et de l'europe
que nous voulons n'admettons plus que
ses souffrances et talent dans nos
villes sur nos trottoirs ou dans nos
écoles nous ne supportons plus que des
enfants sont embastillés séparés de
leurs parents expulsés de l'école nous
sommes révulsé de voir que les familles
ont brûlé parce que leur logement était
dangereux et qu'on ne voulait pas les
reloger il est intolérable que celles et
ceux qui portent assistance aux plus
faibles soient alors pour menacer ce
sont nos liberté à tous qui de proche en
proche soit aujourd'hui en danger nous
trahirions nos principes et nos
consciences si nous restions silencieux
nous savons que tout n'est pas simple et
que nul ne détient de solution magique
mais nous avons vu l'espagne l'italie la
grèce le portugal procéder à des
régularisations massives sans être en
butte cette invasion dont tant de
politiciens attise le fantasme est la
politique qui conduit notre pays dans
une logique qui est aussi celle aussi
réaliste qu'insupportable donné à
forteresse un tel mépris des droits
élémentaires de centaines de milliers
d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants n'est
pas acceptable
nous refusons dans l'être qu'on puisse
nous en appelons un large débat
démocratique pour construire une autre
politique fondée sur le respect des
droits et libertés de tous et qu'ils
fassent de l'ue migrent et non pas un
objet de rejet est un sujet de droit
dignité de la ligue des droits de
l'homme
tant mme lambin et byblos merci d'être
le porte parole de la ligue merci
beaucoup
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
concrètement maintenant on peut faire la
révolution c'est ma de gauche c'est pas
de droite 1 1 tout ça il s'agit d'
humanité d'humanisme de deux simples
démocratie tout simplement et respect
des êtres humains c'est insupportable
sous la gauche comme jamais des grèves
de la faim je me suis fâché avec jospin
chevènement à l'époque parce que j'ai
dit ça manque de mort
ça manque de mort et il ya des morts et
des enfants notamment des bébés et sert
à ce que tu peux nous demandons c'est
que tous les gens qui sont touchés pas
ça peut imaginer que certains peuvent
l'être écrivent alors député maire à eau
au premier ministre au ministre de
l'intérieur au président la république
pour dire à quel point
comme disait jacques brel il disait j'ai
mal aux autres vins tube blanc on est
blanc mais on peut souffrir pour cette
sorte d'apartheid qui est en train de se
créer en france et donc qu'ils écrivent
pour dire qu'ils n'aiment pas respirer
cet air là
en france on est obligé de penser à ses
enfants et les enfants actuellement
france qui se cache ouais donc pas pour
rester c'est donc là moi je m'adresse ya
pas de morale une belle leçon morale
mais on a tous du meilleur en nous en
faut peut-être ce moment de laisser la
scène la place pour laisser monter le
meilleur est cette enfant convoi qui est
pas loin pour y parler il faut les
prendre la main fossés saint pourquoi
c'est là c'est bien peu notre devoir
il ya pas de leçons mais de voir un peu
chacun et chacune de pas si on aura
notre responsabilité
en tout cas on va avoir honte on va voir
où tu en es tu au japon
je voulais lire parce que on dit les
flics la police j'ai lu vous avez
peut-être lu l'interview je vais pas
vous dire toute l'interview peut-être
mais interview d'un policier
question comment se passe votre travail
on est à peu près 50 4 % de l'objectif à
reconduite qui nous a été fixé par le
ministère de l'intérieur
on est donc loin du compte on expulse à
tour de bras on fait des fonds de
tiroirs on va chercher tout ce qui peut
traîner comme étrangers en situation
irrégulière ont fait beaucoup de famille
une famille sever six personnes souvent
sont des gens qui sont là depuis
plusieurs années même les collègues les
plus dures chez nous ne comprennent pas
un exemple la magie pris en charge une
famille africaine et femmes étaient en
france depuis quatre ans venez-y tué son
compagnon avait fait plusieurs demandes
d'asile territoriale en totalisant lui
un enfant
on constate que le gouvernement exclut
de plus en plus de familles avec des
enfants de 3 à 7 ans ce soit le gamin
qui est ici depuis trois ou quatre ans
et qui a appris le français qui nous
sert d'interprète à nous policiers
j'ai vécu le cas d'une famille turque
une petite fille qui lui demandait de
lui préciser le sens de certains mots
pour les expliquer ensuite à ses parents
c'était poignant
vous prenez ces gamins et ses parents
viennent de là où il n'y a rien
ils sont prêts à tout pour s'intégrer ce
qui est impressionnant c'est leur
volonté de s'intégrer dans la société
française ce sont des gens cultivés ils
ont appris à parler le français très
vite je suis un peu surpris quand
j'entends nicolas sarkozy dire qu'il
veut intégrer les gens il ya des
personnes déjà très intégré l1 cucq à
leurs enfants ce qu'il faut faire pour
bien travailler à l'école pour s'insérer
le mieux possible a adjugé 2
française quand ses enfants rentrent
dans le pays de leurs parents ça ne doit
pas être acide et les jeunes majeurs dit
la question ça c'est très dur c'est
choquant parce que lorsque vous allez
chercher ces gamins là la seule chose
qu'ils emmènent ce seront leurs cahiers
ils sont prêts à laisser leur nintendo
ou leurs ballons de foot leurs jouets
même si leurs parents sont modestes ils
essaient d'apporter quelque chose à
leurs gosses
le gamin lui il veut repartir avec ses
livres de classe le savoir qu'il a
acquis en france certains ministres
devraient venir boire ces jeunes là
évidemment on ne peut pas accepter tous
les étrangers en france mais si ces gens
viennent ici c'est qu'ils sont mal chez
eux
schouppe l'état sache qu en les
reconduisant par la porte ils vont
revenir par la fenêtre et j'ai ce canal
j 1 ce matin ça fait cinq ans qu'il
était en france était remarié cotiser
pour sa protection sociale
il s'est fait interpeller à thionville à
être reconduit dans son pays il est
maçon carreleur son patron est embêté
c'était un excellent tous brillé quelle
est la situation des centres de
rétention dit la question c'est de pire
en pire les centres de rétention sont
pleins à craquer faute de place on est
obligé d'emmener des gens de mais sam
toulouse à bordeaux à lille et de faire
ainsi des milliers de kilomètres
dernière question à quoi peuvent servir
les primes au mérite pas un tel contexte
une connerie d'une flic sur une connerie
jouer avec des familles pour faire du
chiffre
c'est inadmissible
vivant
m